on connaît géant d'espère le poète
yvelinois on découvre l'homme amoureux
qui vient de célébrer en mairie de
versailles ces noces de platine 70 ans
de mariage avec son épouse jeanine pour
que de change d'alors d'avoir plus vivre
on a fait comme tout le monde on a ainsi
dû vivre le mieux possible et normal
voir nos chers enfants le mieux possible
le couple d'espère est à la tête d'une
tribu comme il aime la décrire cinq
enfants 14 petits enfants et 11 arrière
petits enfants
mais c'est vieillir ensemble d'être
autonome ils sont toujours deux dans
l'ensemble donc ça c'est merveilleux et
de les voir aussi bien en temps je vois
pas pas encore prendre la main de maman
et dire regardez comme elle est belle
c'est merveilleux effectivement en
terminant tout long terme d'attachement
et d'amour mutuel c'est clairement un
modèle après effectivement là le modèle
des cinq enfants n'était pas celui
transport sera derrière mes entrées en
termes d'affection c est clairement en
veulent
jeanine et jehan se sont rencontrés à
versailles le 17 mai 40 dans un centre
de réfugiés
deux ans plus tard et se sont mariés ici
même dans cette salle de la mairie de
versailles
oui j'aime
je dis oui les élus trésor j'ai tout
arrêté stark là tous les deux ensemble
c'est une joie vous savez et l'amour est
toujours là et l'amour est toujours là
sabri je peux le dire et lui je crois
qu'ils étaient des rochers non vivre au
jour le jour le mieux possible
aimer les gens autour de nous sait pas
si c'est ça c'est fait si simple c'est
donc en toute simplicité entourés de
leur tribu mais non sans émotion que le
couple des spurs et redit oui et pour
l'occasion jurant l'éternel amoureux
offert une bague à jeanine l'amour qui
perdure serait écrit tous les jours